so what are you doing out here there is  a legend in the jungles of the Amazon of  a tree that heals or it could change the  world but if it gets into the wrong  hands  he could awaken a great evil I believe  that the legend is real which was man  I'm gonna find a true wall when I do  just imagine the lives that could be  saved I've been looking for this tree  longer than anybody I've tracked the  legend to every village every island  nothing researching for something it  can't be found  but you've never had the key let's do  something that's safe let's go see some  elephants they're all no elephants in  the Amazon and I don't even like  elephants lady everybody likes elephants  know this about the jungle  everything that you see wants to kill  you and Canada  careful make it smell fear  [Music]  oh my god  who brings a submarine to the Amazon oh  yeah  [Music]  goodnight  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  get it come on Frank I don't got it  [Music]  go the way I planned  [Music]